also in washington despite approval on  capitol hill the president wants  changes to the new coronavirus relief  bill he wants stimulus  payments to be increased from six  hundred dollars to two thousand dollars  this morning house democrats tried to  follow his lead  600 is certainly not enough for  individuals who have been  struggling these past seven months  republicans blocked the move  and is now up to president trump to  either sign or veto the original relief  bill  unemployment benefits are set to expire  the day after christmas so that would be  on  sunday saturday rather house democrats  will make another attempt to boost  stimulus payments on monday